what's going on reject nation we got
ourselves our first official trailer for
miss marvel about a muslim pakistani
american kamala khan getting some more
of that representation in the mcu but before
that let's welcome back our favorite white
i boy like john i cannot talk about this person
i don't care if you're recovering from surgery
you get over here we gotta talk about miss
marvel your favorite marvel character right
man really relates to my experiences in life
you know i'm excited leave a like for john
and let's see what's going on with
this trailer too while we're at it
that's kind of cool actually okay so first off i
just want to say i get it you get what high school
scott pilgrim vibes yeah definitely
maybe they're right i spent too much time being
a muslim fantasy land it's all gonna pay off
it's not really the brown girls
from jersey city you saved the world
what does it feel like
i always thought i wanted this kind of life
but i never imagined any of this you know
oh they like straight up change her powers yeah
it's right out of the comic book cover there ah
it's like right on the copper cover that
looks lovely it does look delightful yeah
it's interesting that's really interesting i mean
i really like the aesthetic choice that they had
especially at the top because as representing
the trailer as someone who's obsessed with
superheroes so i like when you you know you're
doing the thought bubbles that go into the
marvel logo it feels very much like scott pilgrim
versus the world mixed with shazam the best way i
probably describe the vibe that this game us
also with that what was that haley steinfeld
movie with woody harrelson 17 i think it's
called seven teams something like that yeah
especially the relationship that she was having
with uh looks like a counselor yeah yeah a cool
guidance counselor cool guidance counselor yeah
but in the in the comics she gets hit with like
territories the thing that essentially creates in
humans and she has like the embigging abilities
here this looks to be more lining up with this
cosmic captain marvel types of powers yeah in fact
she had like those like chongqi looking kind of
quantum rings activated in something and she even
says directly like the powers she feels cosmic or
something like that yeah i imagine that they're
changing her abilities and i heard rumors that
they might change her abilities because obviously
we have fantastic four coming into the picture
now so you'll have mr fantastic in the mcu so the
powers would be too much correlated so they wanted
to mix it up but they have more going for it than
just the power set and uh yeah it looks like a
cute teen comedy well yeah absolutely and i wonder
if they'll take a chance to maybe do a pivot and
and relate her character to other sides of the mcu
i mean obviously they're going to take her more
cosmic but there's also that ant-man doodle in her
book and there is you know something to at least
iterations of the character where she shares like
molecular dna like you know deep down cellular
connections with herself across multiverses and
across time and space so i'm sure they could
also do a bunch with that but yeah it made
me wonder like what's the nature of this gauntlet
is there some kind of cosmic curse on it is there
terrigen crystals inside of it or something
like that either way i mean i love just the
tone and the spirit that it seems to be evoking
and yeah like you mentioned scott pilgrim you
know the very sort of stylized comic book kind
of look but also you know going further down
that rabbit hole of borrowing from you know teen
and high school movies and stuff like that and
the coming of age stories like on it looks very
fun and relatable in a way that doesn't feel like
you know you're you're stereotypical like oh we're
trying to get woke like i bet there's millions who
disagree with you no i can't imagine it you know
but hey feel free to show me but yeah you know
i mean i love that she does even just as of this
minute and a half clip here feel like a tangible
real relatable person who also has a background
and experience that's very different from you know
what i'm familiar with yeah i think the show
will probably lean into that i don't imagine
like disney is i watch the movie like
cheaper by the dozen the other day which
actually surprised me they're like oh they're they
are leaning into the race element here i imagine
that they will lean into that too because like you
have the conversation in here of like what's my
place in this world where do i belong i don't know
what it's like to be a muslim pakistani teenager
but i imagine that they would deal with what that
must feel like as a teen living in new jersey what
your position in the world is by the way speaking
of new jersey man like so much goes on over there
an nj in the mcu they don't get enough credit
it's always about new york city but you know
what we got like west view captain america when
her soldier took place there i feel like there's
another thing that's missing those are the two
that came to mind when i was watching this and
i really feel like that camaraderie relationship
that she's having with her friend where she's like
showing her power sets does remind me a lot of
what they do in shazam as well i don't know who
the bad guy is i don't really know what's gonna
imagine captain marvel might make an appearance in
this show we'll see but this seems to be capturing
this is supposed to be the audience cipher for
what it feels like for kids who probably admire
the marvel cinematic universe as well um but yeah
she looks great she looks charming this looks
fun but as far as like what i'm looking forward
to most out of the mcu i don't look like i'm the
target demographic for it i mean it looks adorable
so it's not really a criticism not like oh my
god i'm dying to watch this right now because
it feels like more like a cute teen show however
i i do like those who i mentioned your brother
does and i was like you know what i like this
cheesy crap i feel like that's the same way i'm
gonna restaurant it's like this looks like just
a good family time we're probably gonna have a
lot of heart and a lot of good messages yeah
i'm a sensitive fellow sometimes i'm a sucker
for for those kinds of things anyway guys what you
think about the miss marvel trailer is it better
than what you imagine the thor love and thunder
trailer will look like leave your thoughts down
below subscribe to get accepted into the reject
nation click that like button last but not least
adelia chamberlain you to me are the ms
marvel of this channel i would love to see
making a lot of other women at the
patreon jealous but please continue i mean
you are one of a few because it's
the multiverse variants but today
you are the marvels you're you're captain
marvel you're miss marvel you're maria ram
but you're photon you're everybody adelia
you're the locust person here because you're
from everywhere you're every ethnicity you
are every she's probably the white of smarts
hey what's white if not the absence of color with
which we can fill the blank canvas to the you
know uh heart's content and adelia i mean you are
somebody who has a big imagination just waiting to
be let out to the world begging for that one last
push of colorful brightness to get your message
out there to get your spirit and your wonderful
qualities to the world you are the most ethnic
person i know so hey keep it really love you
very much and we'll uh we'll catch you next time
you